accused of plagiarism over a story that
is almost identical to one
martin luther king jr told back in 1965.
harris has repeatedly said this happened
when she went to a civil rights rally as
a young girl my mother used to have a
very funny story but i was
fussing and and and she said kamala what
do you want and i said
and this is how she would say it and she
said come like what do you want
and i said freedom
her story very similar to one mlk
told about a black girl and a white
police officer
he said quote what do you want the
policeman asked her gruffly
and the little girl looked at him
straight in the eye and answered
feed him all right greg
what do you think about this one
i don't know man when i fought in nam
alongside brian williams
i heard a lot of crazy stories and it's
pr it's possible
that this could have happened to both
people uh or she believes it happened
like the liz warren defense where maybe
her mother
told her this story and and she believed
it the way liz warren believed in her
native american
ancestry or perhaps she was watching too
much elmer fudd and the subliminal
you know freedom you know freedom isn't
free it's a free country
uh but i also believe that this is true
equality
she looked at joe biden and she says
what a man can do
i can do better i see your speech
plagiarism
and i raise you a family history
juan what do you think happened here how
did something like this go down
it doesn't look good to me jesse at best
maybe she was using it like a parable
and if that's the case
she should say so because otherwise it
really doesn't look good
it looks better than uh that than a
candidate we know who uh
you know built a whole political career
and saying the first black president
wasn't an american citizen
uh dana you know if you're gonna
plagiarize don't
plagiarize martin luther king i mean
maybe pick someone a little less famous
you know what surprises me jesse is that
nobody
had had noticed this before now
i mean she is uh going to be the vice
president
she's made history there she's told the
story 100 times
and we're only finding out about it now
that seems not good
martha what do you think the chances are
that a reporter asks her about it at one
of her many
many press availabilities yeah i was
just you know trying to find out if she
had any response to this yet and i don't
see
anything yet um i can only say that
perhaps she's following in the footsteps
of the president-elect who was also
uh saw his presidential run derailed by
plagiarism
accounts back in the 80s so uh maybe
this you know sort of runs in the
in the new administration family um and
my only
i think about what she could possibly
say is that she said she said
freedom and in martin luther king's
story
he said feed them he said the little
girl said you feed them so it's
different
yes that sounds like the hilaria baldwin
defense
just a little bit different all right
martha has to go
because she's gonna get ready for the
special election coverage so
martha yeah